Have you ever tried BBQ on BBQ? Picture this. Freshly prepared crispy seasoned chicken that's tossed in a smoky barbecue glaze and topped with a creamy barbecue sauce. Can't picture it? Well you can try it now at Tim's. Get our new BBQ crispy chicken loaded bowls and wraps for a limited time. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local Crisis Centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. Mount Macedon looms 65km northwest of Melbourne City, its tree-clad mountainous peak overshadowing a small, gold rush-era heritage township bearing its namesake. From the summit, Mount Macedon provides a sprawling scenic view of the surrounding native forests and rural Victorian countryside, with the cityscape in the far distance. Several creeks branch out from the mountain, including two that feed into the much larger Maribanong River, a winding 40km waterway that heads chiefly southward through the factory districts and residential suburbs of the northwestern fringe of the city, before joining Melbourne's central waterway, the Yarrow River, eventually emptying into Port Phillip Bay. As the second major river in metropolitan Melbourne, the Maribanong originally served as an arterial shipping route in the city's west, fostering the development of the area's industrial growth. As a result, the quality of the water degraded, with decades of contamination, pollution and litter turning the river a murky-brown colour. In recent times, most of the riverside industry has been closed, with the Maribanong re-established as a recreational hub for boating, fishing, rowing and cruises.
你试过在烧烤上吃烧烤吗？想象一下：新鲜出炉、外酥里嫩的调味鸡肉，裹上烟熏烧烤釉面，再淋上浓郁的烧烤酱。想象不出来？现在你可以在蒂姆餐厅品尝到了。快来限时购买我们全新的烧烤脆鸡碗和卷饼吧。我们的节目涉及严肃且通常令人心碎的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。有关保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您手机应用上或我们网站上的本期节目说明。马其顿山耸立在墨尔本市西北偏北65公里处，其树木葱郁的山峰俯瞰着一个以其名字命名的小型淘金热时期历史小镇。从山顶望去，马其顿山可以一览周围原始森林和维多利亚州乡村的广阔美景，远处则是城市天际线。几条小溪从山中分流而出，其中包括两条汇入更大的马里比尔农河的支流。马里比尔农河是一条蜿蜒40公里的水道，主要向南穿过该市西北边缘的工厂区和住宅郊区，最后汇入墨尔本的中央水道亚拉河，最终注入菲利普港湾。作为墨尔本大都市的第二大河流，马里比尔农河最初曾是该市西部的主干航运路线，促进了当地工业的发展。因此，由于数十年的污染、污染和垃圾，河水质量恶化，变成浑浊的棕色。近年来，大部分河畔工业已经关闭，马里比尔农河已被重建为划船、钓鱼、赛艇和游船的休闲中心。
An abundance of bushland, parks and sporting fields now border the length of the river, which is framed by various bike paths and walking trails. At around midday on Thursday, February 5, 2015, two walkers were strolling along the eastern banks of the Maribanong River in Mooney Ponds, a suburb 6km out of Melbourne. They passed the renowned Boathouse Restaurant, owned by celebrity chef Gary Meaghan, which was bustling as usual, as was the Anglers' Tavern, a riverside pub located a little further downstream on the adjacent shore. The Maribanong Park, which flanks the popular eatery, was full of visitors, dog walkers, joggers and children enjoying the warm summer day. At 1.30pm, as the pair continued along the palm and gum tree-lined track, they noticed something floating upstream in the murky waters of the river. It was a white plastic grocery bag with something inside. Upon taking a closer look, they immediately contacted police who promptly arrived to the riverbank. Curious patrons of the nearby establishments watched on as officers stood on a wooden jetty and used a pole to fish the bag from the water.
郁郁葱葱的灌木丛、公园和运动场现在绵延在河流两岸，河岸四周环绕着各种自行车道和步行小径。2015年2月5日星期四中午左右，两名散步者正沿着墨尔本市郊6公里处的穆尼庞兹的马里比尔农河东岸漫步。他们经过了由名厨加里·梅根经营的著名船屋餐厅，这里一如既往地热闹非凡，稍下游相邻岸边的河畔酒吧垂钓者酒馆也是如此。毗邻这家热门餐馆的马里比尔农公园里挤满了游客、遛狗者、慢跑者和享受温暖夏日的儿童。下午1点30分，当两人继续沿着这条两旁种满棕榈树和桉树的小径前行时，他们注意到河水浑浊的水面上有什么东西在逆流而上。这是一个白色的塑料杂货袋，里面装着东西。仔细一看，他们立即联系了警方，警方随即赶到河岸。附近场所的好奇顾客驻足观看，警官们站在一个木制码头上，用一根杆子把袋子从水里捞了上来。
They placed it on the jetty and peered inside, discovering the bag contained what appeared to be a reasonably fresh, severed human limb. The scene was shot in the back of the car. Officers at the scene conducted an initial examination of the limb and identified it to be the forearm of a Caucasian male severed at the elbow and wrist. They were certain the victim's hand had been intentionally removed to hinder efforts to identify the remains through fingerprint analysis. There was only one distinguishable feature on the forearm, a faded tattoo of a devilish caricature wearing baggy pants and holding a three-pronged pitchfork in its left hand and what looked like a spray can in its right. The grisly discovery sparked a full-scale search of the Maribyrnong River, which was an enormous and time-consuming task encompassing the Water Police, State Emergency Service and the Police Search and Rescue Squad. As the various teams began trudging the riverbank and its rocky surrounds, sifting through the junk and muck that had accumulated over the years, police divers in full scuba gear plunged into the shallow murky waters to scour beneath the surface. Their vision was severely limited as they cautiously navigated around the large tree branches and submerged items that littered the riverbed.
他们把它放在码头上往里张望，发现袋子里装着一个看起来相当新鲜的被砍断的人体肢体。这一幕是在车内拍摄的。现场警官对该肢体进行了初步检查，确认它是白人男性的前臂，在肘部和手腕处被切断。他们确认为，受害者的手是被故意切除的，以阻碍通过指纹分析识别遗骸的努力。前臂上只有一个明显的特征，即一个褪色的恶魔漫画纹身，穿着宽松的裤子，左手拿着一把三叉戟，右手拿着看起来像喷漆罐的东西。这个可怕的发现引发了对马里比尔农河的全方位搜查，这是一项艰巨且耗时的工作，水警、州紧急服务局和警察搜查与救援队都参与其中。随着各搜救小队开始跋涉河岸及周围的岩石，筛查多年来积聚的垃圾和污泥，身穿全套水肺装备的警察潜水员潜入浅而浑浊的水中搜寻水面以下。由于视野严重受限，他们小心翼翼地绕过河床上散落的大树枝和淹没的物品。
In a slow and methodical process, police boats equipped with sonar equipment scanned the depths of the river two kilometres in either direction from the side of the discovery, overseen by a police helicopter circling above. Search efforts were complicated by the fact that the Maribyrnong was a tidal river influenced by Port Phillip Bay, which sat at its large coastal mouth. The changing ocean tides altered the river's flow and water levels, causing debris to constantly shift directions up and downstream. Police understood that if there were more human remains to be discovered in the waterway, they may have since been displaced and directed elsewhere. It also meant the location where the forearm had been found wasn't necessarily the same place that had been originally discarded. The intensive police presence caught the attention of the media and passing onlookers who swarmed the scene to observe the grim search. Meanwhile, detectives began door-knocking the local area and collecting footage from security cameras located near the riverbank. The grisly discovery came as a shock to the residents of Mooney Ponds, where such horrific crimes were unheard of in their esteemed and trendy suburb, populated by young professionals, families and retirees.
在一个缓慢而有条不紊的过程中，配备声纳设备的警用船只在发现地点两侧各两公里的河深处进行扫描，上方由一架警用直升机盘旋监督。搜寻工作因马里比尔农河是一条受菲利普港湾影响的潮汐河而变得复杂，菲利普港湾位于其巨大的海岸河口。不断变化的海洋潮汐改变了河流的流速和水位，导致碎片不断上下游变换方向。警方明白，如果在水道中发现更多的人类遗骸，它们可能已经被移位并被冲到其他地方。这也意味着发现前臂的地点不一定是最初抛尸的地点。密集的警察警力引起了媒体和过往旁观者的注意，他们蜂拥至现场观察严峻的搜查。与此同时，侦探们开始对当地进行挨家挨户的走访，并收集河岸附近安全摄像头拍摄的画面。这一可怕的发现让穆尼庞兹的居民感到震惊，在他们这个受人尊敬、充满时尚气息、居住着年轻专业人士、家庭和退休人员的郊区，从未听说过如此可怕的罪恶。
Due to the method in which the body was dismembered and to the perpetrator's calculated efforts to conceal the victim's identity, room is circulated as to whether the death was gang-related. Just over three hours after the forearm was discovered, search crews had shifted two kilometers downstream to the suburb of Essendon West. There, under the Apton Street pedestrian bridge, a popular dive spot for swimmers, police and state emergency service personnel spotted a second plastic bag in the water. They pulled it out and discovered it contained another human limb, although this one was not as easily identifiable as the first. Hours later, at 7pm, two kilometers upstream from where the forearm was originally sighted, police spotted a black plastic bag floating down the river. Upon retrieving it, the bag contained what officers could only describe as a small amount of human flesh. The recovered human remains were sent to the Victorian Institute of Forensic Medicine for examination, where forensic pathologists performed multiple autopsies to confirm all the body parts belonged to the same unidentified male. They also determined the remains had been in the river for up to seven days.
由于肢解尸体的方法以及凶手蓄意隐瞒受害者身份的努力，人们开始流传这起死亡事件是否与黑帮有关。在前臂被发现后三个多小时，搜救人员已将搜寻范围向下游转移了两公里，至埃森顿西部郊区。在那里，在作为游泳热门跳水地点的阿普顿街人行天桥下，警察和州紧急服务人员在水中发现了第二个塑料袋。他们把它拉出来，发现里面装着另一截人体肢体，尽管这截肢体不像第一截那样容易辨认。几小时后，即晚上7点，在最初发现前臂的上游两公里处，警察发现一个黑色塑料袋漂浮在河面上。收回后，袋子里装着警察只能形容为少量的人体肌肉。回收的人体遗骸被送往维多利亚法医学研究所进行检查，法医病理学家进行了多次尸检，以确认所有身体部位都属于同一名未辨认身份的男性。他们还确定遗骸在河里呆了长达七天。
It was clear to police that the victim had been murdered and dismembered elsewhere before the Maribanong had been used as a dumping ground to discard his remains. They were certain more body parts had yet to be discovered, but given the late hour and the lack of visibility, dive efforts were suspended until the following morning. Search efforts continued on land overnight as the gruesome nature of the case put pressure on police to swiftly identify the victim and capture his killer. The next morning, Friday, February 6th, divers re-entered the river at first light as police continued to comb the adjoining landscape and surrounding streets. After failing to uncover any further remains by midday, the focus of the search was shifted to the area surrounding the Afton Street Bridge, the site of the second discovery. At 1.30pm, divers began extensively combing that portion of the river, but after hours of fruitless searching, were forced to call it a day. The next step for homicide detectives was to try and identify the victim using the only clue they had thus far, the distinctive forearm tattoo of the pitchfork wielding devil. They cross-checked the image with missing person reports and the criminal database whilst making inquiries with local tattoo parlours and graffiti artists.
警方很清楚，受害者是在其他地方被谋杀和肢解的，然后马里比尔农河被用作倾倒其遗骸的倾倒场。他们确信还有更多的身体部位尚未被发现，但鉴于时间已晚且能见度不足，潜水搜寻工作被暂停，直到第二天早上。由于案件的残酷性质给警方施加了迅速查明受害者身份并抓获凶手的压力，搜救工作在夜间仍在陆地上继续。第二天早上，即2月6日星期五，天刚亮潜水员就重新进入河中，而警察则继续梳理邻近的景观和周围的街道。在中午之前未能发现任何进一步的遗骸后，搜寻的重点转移到了第二次发现的地点阿夫顿街大桥周围的区域。下午1点30分，潜水员开始对河流的那一部分进行广泛的梳理，但在进行了几个小时毫无结果的搜查后，被迫收工。凶杀案侦探的下一步是试图利用他们迄今为止唯一的线索——挥舞三叉戟的恶魔的独特前臂纹身来确认受害者的身份。他们将该图像与失踪人员报告和犯罪数据库进行了交叉核对，同时向当地纹身店和涂鸦艺术家进行了询问。
To hasten efforts, police released an image of the tattoo to the media in the hope that a member of the public might recognise the artwork and come forward. In an accompanying statement, Detective Inspector Mick Hughes stated, The killer made steps to try and hide his identity and were taking steps to try and identify him. Detective Hughes expressed sympathy towards the victim's family who would likely learn of their loved one's death from the ensuing media reports. Quote, I think it's important from the family's perspective. We know this is a terrible way for them to find out, but I think it will get a breakthrough in our investigation. Meanwhile, the search of the Maribyrnong River continued. The waters hadn't been closed off to the public, so river-goers continued to populate the waterway as it was scoured for body parts. On the third morning of the police search, a woman took to the water in her rowboat and headed towards the Maribyrnong Road Bridge in Mooney Ponds, near the location where the forearm was recovered.
为了加快搜寻工作，警方将纹身的照片公之于媒体，希望公众能认出这幅艺术品并挺身而出。在一份随附的声明中，侦探督察米克·休斯表示：“凶手采取了措施试图隐藏他的身份，我们正在采取措施试图确认他的身份。”休斯侦探对受害者的家属表示同情，他们很可能会从随后的媒体报道中得知亲人的死讯。“引用原话，我认为这从家属的角度来看很重要。我们知道这对他们来说是一种可怕的发现方式，但我认为这将在我们的调查中取得突破。”与此同时，对马里比尔农河的搜查仍在继续。河水并未对公众关闭，因此去河边的人继续涌入水道，寻找身体部位。在警方搜查的第三天，一名妇女划着赛艇下水，朝穆尼庞兹的马里比尔农路大桥驶去，这里靠近找回前臂的地点。
At 11am, she spotted a plastic bag floating under the bridge and paddled over to take a closer look. Realising it contained flesh, she caught the attention of a passing police boat and used her paddle to push the bag over to the officers. Three and a half hours later, two local men were walking their dogs alongside the river. As they passed the Essendon Canoe Club on the adjacent side, they spotted a white plastic bag that had washed up on the riverbank and wedged between rocks. The men recognised a grey human knee protruding from the bag and immediately flagged down a police boat. Reporters at the scene crowded around the men as one explained, I feel awful, it's someone. Whilst the other described the discovery as surreal, adding,
上午11点，她发现一个塑料袋漂浮在桥下，便划过去仔细查看。意识到里面装着肉，她引起了一艘过往巡逻艇的注意，并用桨把袋子推向了警官。三个半小时后，两名当地男子带着他们的狗沿河散步。当他们路过相邻岸边的埃森顿独木舟俱乐部时，他们发现了一个被冲上河岸并卡在岩石之间的白色塑料袋。这几名男子认出了从袋子里伸出来的一个灰色的膝盖，并立即拦住了一艘警艇。现场的记者们挤在这几名男子周围，其中一人解释说：“我觉得太可怕了，那是个人。”而另一人则将这一发现描述为超现实的，并补充道：
kids are enjoying a nice game of cricket and there's a body part floating near them. As the two latest discoveries were within 200 metres of the Maribyrnong Road Bridge, police shifted their attention back to this area. But after another day of searching, their efforts yielded no further discoveries. Meanwhile, the image of the forearm tattoo was circulating on news sites throughout Australia and as far away as the United Kingdom and New Zealand. As no one had immediately come forward to identify the tattooed man, it was presumed he either had a little family or lived interstate or overseas. Police had appealed for anyone with information to contact Crime Stoppers, an organisation which allows people to provide anonymous information to authorities. The service was flooded with calls, but none led to the identity of the victim. Then, the Victoria Police Facebook page received messages from the public alerting them to a post on the internet forum website Reddit,
孩子们正在开心地打板球，而一个身体部位就在他们附近漂浮。由于最近的两次发现都在马里比尔农路桥200米以内，警方将注意力重新集中到了这一地区。但在又搜寻了一天之后，他们的努力没有取得任何新的发现。与此同时，前臂纹身的照片正在澳大利亚的新闻网站上流传，甚至远至英国和新西兰。由于没有人立即站出来识别这个有纹身的男子，人们推测他要么家庭人口很少，要么住在州外或海外。警方呼吁任何有线索的人联系犯罪终结者组织，这是一个允许人们向当局提供匿名信息的组织。该服务接到了大量电话，但没有一个电话指向受害者的身份。随后，维多利亚州警察局的Facebook页面收到了公众的消息，提醒他们注意互联网论坛网站Reddit上的一篇帖子，
in which users had identified the origin of the tattoo's pitchfork wielding devil. The image was featured on a 1997 album titled Tooth and Nail, released by three-piece Australian punk band Downtime. The album's cover art depicted the exact same devil from the tattoo. The only difference was that instead of a spray can in its right hand, Downtime's devil was holding a bouquet of yellow-arum lilies, an ornamental plant variety commonly displayed at funerals. Given the similarities between the tattoo and the album's artwork, the websloots who made the connection speculated whether the victim was known to the band. Downtime had since drifted apart. Lead singer Billy Hughes died in a car crash in 2011. Drama Brendon Peace no longer performed, and bassist James Meek now played for various other groups.
其中用户们认出了纹身上挥舞三叉戟的恶魔的起源。该图像出现在澳大利亚三人朋克乐队Downtime于1997年发行的一张名为《Tooth and Nail》的专辑中。专辑的封面艺术描绘了纹身中完全相同的恶魔。唯一的区别是，Downtime的恶魔右手拿的不是喷漆罐，而是一束黄马蹄莲，这是一种通常在葬礼上展示的观赏植物品种。鉴于纹身与专辑封面之间的相似之处，建立这种联系的网络侦探猜测受害者是否认识该乐队。Downtime此后已经解散。主唱比利·休斯于2011年在一次车祸中丧生。鼓手布伦登·皮斯不再表演，而贝斯手詹姆斯·米克现在为其他各种乐队演奏。
Although the band originally hailed from Sydney, they had amassed the decent underground following in Melbourne during the 90s. Former band manager Matt Reese was certain he would remember if a devoted Downtime fan had gotten the tattoo at the time, as they surely would have come forward to show it off to their idols. As it turned out, Downtime's bassist James Meek had copied the devil artwork for his band's album cover from a skateboarding and graffiti magazine. He had taken some creative liberties in his reproduction, giving the devil a bouquet of yellow lilies instead of the can of spray paint it held in the original magazine version. The magazine artwork and the victim's tattoo were compared side by side, revealing an exact match. Evolving news reports on the tattoo caught the attention of local Melbourne resident, Ronald Whitmore, who arrived at the North Melbourne police station to inform officers that his 32-year-old son, Brendon David Bernard,
尽管该乐队最初来自悉尼，但他们在90年代在墨尔本积累了相当可观的地下粉丝群。前乐队经理马特·里斯确信，如果当时有忠实的Downtime粉丝纹了这个纹身，他一定会记得，因为他们肯定会挺身向偶像炫耀。事实证明，Downtime的贝斯手詹姆斯·米克是从一本滑板和涂鸦杂志上抄袭了恶魔插图来作为他乐队的专辑封面的。他在复刻时进行了艺术创作，让恶魔手里拿着一束黄百合，而不是原杂志版本中拿着的喷漆罐。将杂志插图与受害者的纹身进行并排比较，结果显示完全吻合。不断发展的关于纹身的本地新闻报道引起了墨尔本当地居民罗纳德·怀特莫尔的注意，他来到北墨尔本警察局，告知警官他32岁的儿子布伦登·大卫·伯纳德（Brendon David Bernard），
had the exact same devil tattoo on his inner forearm, having it inked when he was 16 years old. The last time Ronald had seen his son was over a month earlier on Christmas Day of 2014, but Brendon's lack of contact since the holiday was not unusual, as he often went long periods of time without getting in touch. As such, the family had not been concerned about his whereabouts, and he hadn't been reported as missing. Brendon's friends knew him simply as B, and he wore a distinctive chain around his neck adorned with the letter. He was the eldest of four children, one of whom had since relocated to Europe, but the other two resided in Melbourne. His mother had passed away in 2008. For the past five years, Brendon had been homeless, intermittently staying at men's shelters until the end of 2012,
他的前臂内侧也有完全相同的恶魔纹身，这是他在16岁时纹的。罗纳德上次见到儿子是在一个多月前的2014年圣诞节，但布伦登自假期以来一直没有联系并不罕见，因为他经常很长时间不与家人联系。因此，家人并没有担心他的去向，也没有将他报为失踪人员。布伦登的朋友们简单地叫他B，他的脖子上戴着一条带有字母的独特项链。他是四个孩子中的老大，其中一人后来搬到了欧洲，但另外两人住在墨尔本。他的母亲于2008年去世。在过去的五年里，布伦登一直无家可归，断断续续地住在男士收容所，直到2012年底，
when he took to couchsurfing between the homes of his friends. A long-term heroin user, he was also known to deal drugs which caused a rift between his family. Although they did not agree with his life choices, they still cared deeply for Brendon and hoped he would get his life back on track. They made sure to touch base with him every once in a while, including at Christmas time. To determine if there was a familial connection, Ronald Whitmore provided investigators with his own DNA to compare against the unidentified remains. A significantly faster process than checking the DNA against their extensive databases. As police awaited the results of the test, Detective Inspector Mick Hughes fronted the media announcing the tattoo had been recognized by the victim's family. He disclosed the victim to be a man aged in his 30s who lived on the fringes of Melbourne's CBD,
当时他开始在朋友家借宿。作为一名长期的海洛因吸食者，他也以为人贩毒而闻名，这导致了他的家庭破裂。尽管他们不同意他的人生选择，但他们依然深切关怀布伦登，并希望他能重回正轨。他们确保每隔一段时间与他联系一次，包括在圣诞节期间。为了确定是否存在血缘关系，罗纳德·怀特莫尔向调查人员提供了他自己的DNA，以便与未识别的遗骸进行比对。与对照他们庞大的数据库相比，这是一个明显更快的过程。在警方等待测试结果的同时，侦探督察米克·休斯在媒体面前宣布，这个纹身已被受害者的家人认出。他透露受害者是一名30多岁的男子，住在墨尔本CBD的边缘，
but withheld Brendon Bernard's name, explaining he would not disclose his identity until the DNA had been confirmed through forensic testing. Although he expressed confidence that they now knew who the victim was, remarking, everything points to that family's relative, adding that a motive for the murder and his exact cause of death remained unclear. Detective Hughes thanked the public and media for their support during the course of their investigations, stating, The response from the public has been tremendous. Despite the confronting nature of these discoveries, people have acted quickly and contacted police immediately. The information provided has enabled investigators to act quickly and secure the items proving crucial in the investigation. I'd appeal to the offender out there.
但隐去了布伦登·伯纳德的名字，并解释说在通过法医检测确认DNA之前，他不会透露其身份。尽管他表示相信他们现在知道了受害者是谁，并评论道“一切都指向那个家庭的亲属”，但他补充说，谋杀的动机和他的确切死因仍不清楚。休斯侦探感谢公众和媒体在调查过程中给予的支持，并表示：“公众的反应非常巨大。尽管这些发现具有直面性，但人们行动迅速，立即联系了警方。提供的信息使调查人员能够迅速采取行动并获得在调查中证明至关重要的物品。我在此呼吁罪犯出来。”
We are methodically working our way towards him or her, and if they would like to contact crime stoppers, we'll certainly make ourselves available for interview. A lot of people find themselves in circumstances they have no control over. Obviously, if there are associates of the offender, perhaps who are not actively involved in the death, we'd certainly be interested in talking to them if they come forward. The results of Ronald Whitmore's DNA tests came back positive, confirming a familial match existed between himself and the victim. This result, coupled with the Taddu identification, confirmed the Maribyrnong River remains were those of Brendan Bernard. The verification devastated Brendan's family, who struggled to comprehend the depravity of his death and the horrific ordeal he suffered. Ronald provided police with a recent photograph of his deceased son to help with their investigations.
我们正在有条不紊地追捕他或她，如果他们愿意联系犯罪终结者，我们当然会抽出时间接受采访。许多人发现自己处于无法控制的环境中。显然，如果罪犯的同伙可能没有积极参与这起谋杀，如果他们挺身而出，我们当然有兴趣与他们交谈。罗纳德·怀特莫尔的DNA测试结果呈阳性，证实了他与受害者之间存在血缘关系。这一结果，加上纹身的识别，证实了马里比尔农河的遗骸属于布伦登·伯纳德。这一核实让布伦登的家人悲痛欲绝，他们难以理解他死亡的残忍以及他所遭受的可怕折磨。罗纳德向警方提供了一张他已故儿子的近期照片，以协助调查。
He portrayed a smiling and relaxed Brendan as he stood at the tram stop on the corner of Gertrude and Napier streets in Fitzroy. His shoulder-length brown hair was covered by a black hat, which matched his black attire, a collection of key chains dangling around his neck. The photo was released to the media, publicly naming Brendan Bernard as the man whose remains had been found in the river, and the hunt for his killer was initiated. Homicide detectives extended their investigations to the locations Brendan was known to frequent and began questioning his relatives and friends. John Ankovich, Brendan's stepfather, came forward as one of the last people to have seen Brendan in the days preceding the discovery of his remains. John maintained good relationship with his stepson, with the pair having last seen each other on Tuesday, January 27. Nine days before Brendan's body parts were found, he met his stepfather outside John's city-based office, where he asked to borrow some money. John agreed, transferring $100 into Brendan's bank account, but he hadn't heard from him since.
照片中，布伦登站在菲茨罗伊格特鲁德街和纳皮尔街交汇处的电车车站，面带微笑，神情放松。他及肩的棕色头发戴着一顶黑色的帽子，与他的黑色着装相配，脖子上挂着一串钥匙链。这张照片被公之于媒体，公开点名布伦登·伯纳德就是遗骸在河中被发现的男子，搜捕凶手的行动随即展开。凶杀案侦探将调查范围扩大到布伦登常去的地点，并开始讯问他的亲属和朋友。布伦登的继父约翰·安科维奇作为在发现遗骸前几天见到布伦登的最后几个人之一挺身而出。约翰与继子保持着良好的关系，两人最后一次见面是在1月27日星期二。在布伦登的尸体部位被发现的九天前，他在约翰位于市中心的办公室外面遇到了他的继父，并要求借一些钱。约翰同意了，将100澳元转入布伦登的银行账户，但自那以后他再也没有听到过他的消息。
When John saw the devil tattoo in media reports, he immediately recognized it as similar to Brendan's, but the image was blurry, so he wasn't 100% certain. Wanting to make sure his stepson was all right, John proceeded to try to find him. He knew Brendan was staying with a friend, Matthew Brennan, who lived in an apartment on O'Shennessey Street in North Melbourne. The apartment was part of a multi-story housing commission complex owned by the Australian government, which provided shelter to low-income earners and people dependent on social welfare. Matthew had been allowing Brendan to stay at his place temporarily free of rent. When John visited the apartment looking for Brendan, Matthew seemed reluctant to open the door, informing him that Brendan had packed up his things and left the week prior. Detectives checked CCTV footage and were able to confirm that Brendan had met his stepfather in the CBD on January 27 as John had stated, but were unable to track his movements from there onwards. They approached Matthew Brennan, finding him in the company of another friend, Konstantinos Spaliaris, who resided in the same O'Shennessey Street housing complex.
当约翰在媒体报道中看到恶魔纹身时，他立即认出它与布伦登的很相似，但图像很模糊，所以他不是100%确定。为了确保继父没事，约翰开始寻找他。他知道布伦登和一位名叫马修·布伦南的朋友住在一起，后者住在北墨尔本奥肖内西街的一间公寓里。这间公寓是由澳大利亚政府拥有的一栋多层公房综合体的一部分，为低收入者和依赖社会福利的人提供庇护。马修一直允许布伦登免费在他的地方暂住。当约翰去公寓找布伦登时，马修似乎不愿意开门，并告诉他布伦登在一周前已经收拾好东西离开了。侦探们检查了闭路电视录像，并能够证实布伦登正如约翰所说的那样于1月27日在CBD会见了继父，但无法追踪他从那以后的行踪。他们找到了马修·布伦南，发现他和另一个朋友康斯坦蒂诺斯·斯帕利亚里斯在一起，后者住在同一栋奥肖内西街公房综合体里。
When asked about Brendan's whereabouts, Matthew and Konstantinos told the officers that he had, quote, done a runner, after he was confronted by two unnamed men for selling them drugs they described as batshit. Neither of the men had heard from Brendan since. Detectives proceeded to door-knock the apartment complex to see if any of the residents had witnessed anything unusual in the days before Brendan's departure. Neighbours recalled seeing Brendan at Matthew's apartment on Tuesday, January 27, after he had returned from meeting his stepfather in the city. The front door to Matthew's apartment was open and the two men were seen in the company of Konstantinos Spaliaris, his girlfriend and a fourth resident named Edward Hill. Several neighbours recalled hearing prolonged yelling and screaming emanating from the group. One resident, who resided in the apartment above, told investigators he overheard a fight in the apartment below that lasted from 10 to 20 minutes. Another neighbour added that she heard strange noises that sounded like a power drill being used.
当被问及布伦登的下落时，马修和康斯坦蒂诺斯告诉警官，在被两个不知名男子指控向他们出售他们形容为“胡扯”的毒品后，他“跑路”了。两人自那以后再也没有听到过布伦登的消息。侦探们开始对公寓大楼进行挨家挨户的走访，看看是否有居民在布伦登离开前的几天里目睹了任何异常情况。邻居们回忆说，1月27日星期二，布伦登从城里见完继父回来后，曾在马修的公寓里看到过他。马修公寓的前门是开着的，人们看到这两个人与康斯坦蒂诺斯·斯帕利亚里斯、他的女朋友以及第四位名叫爱德华·希尔的居民在一起。几位邻居回忆说听到这群人发出长时间的叫喊和尖叫。住在楼上公寓的一名居民告诉调查人员，他无意中听到楼下公寓发生了一场持续10到20分钟的争吵。另一位邻居补充说，她听到奇怪的噪音，听起来像是在使用电钻。
Police looked into the backgrounds of all those in attendance at Matthew Brennan's apartment on January 27, starting with the host. 36-year-old Matthew Brennan was the youngest of four children. He left high school in year 11, working sporadically as a factory hand. When he was 19, his family was struck by a sequence of tragedies, starting when his mother died of cancer, followed by losing his brother to a drug overdose and his father dying of a stroke, all within a three-year timespan. Illicit drugs had been a problem throughout much of Matthew's life. He started smoking cannabis at age 12, before moving on to amphetamines at 15 and heroin at 17. He also experimented with benzodiazepines and hallucinogens, including LSD and magic mushrooms. By the time he was 19 years old, he was dependent on heroin and began identifying as a Nazi skinhead. Matthew began psychological treatment in 2012, during which a doctor noted he had psychopathic features contrasted with anxiety, vulnerability and inferiority, suggesting his identification with Nazi beliefs was part of a coping mechanism to deal with negative emotions. In August 2014, he was admitted to the Royal Melbourne Hospital after suffering a methamphetamine-induced psychosis.
警方调查了1月27日在马修·布伦南公寓里的所有人的背景，从房东开始。36岁的马修·布伦南是四个孩子中的老小。他在11年级时辍学，零星地做着工厂杂工。19岁时，他的家庭遭遇了一连串的悲剧，先是母亲死于癌症，接着是弟弟因吸毒过量身亡，父亲死于中风，这一切都发生在三年之内。非法毒品一直是马修一生的困扰。他在12岁时开始吸食大麻，15岁时转向安非他命，17岁时转向海洛因。他还尝试过苯二氮卓类药物和致幻剂，包括LSD和迷幻蘑菇。到19岁时，他已经对海洛因产生依赖，并开始以纳粹光头党自居。马修于2012年开始接受心理治疗，期间一位医生指出他具有精神病态特征，并与焦虑、脆弱和自卑形成对比，这表明他认同纳粹信仰是应对消极情绪的一种应对机制。2014年8月，他因患有甲基苯丙胺引发的精神病被送入墨尔本皇家医院。
Matthew had two sons with a woman who was also struggling with drug addiction, resulting in their children being placed in the care of Matthew's stepmother. Although he had no history of violent crime, he had appeared in court three times between 1995 and 2002, having been convicted of over 130 offenses from those three appearances, mostly in relation to dishonesty charges. He was imprisoned for 14 months in 2002 for skipping bail, burglary, theft, handling stolen goods, possession of heroin, and possession of a controlled weapon. After his release in 2003, Matthew obtained accommodation from the Ministry of Housing in the Oceanic Street apartment complex. Although he was able to stay out of legal trouble in the following 13 years, he continued his ongoing use of illicit drugs. Matthew's friend, 31-year-old Konstantinos Beliaris was one of three sons. His parents divorced when he was young and he was raised by his father, with whom he had a strained relationship, contributing to Konstantinos' anger issues. By his 16th birthday, after his father threatened to kick him out, Konstantinos left home on his own accord, dropping out of high school in year 11 to begin a plumbing apprenticeship that he never finished.
马修与一名同样在与毒瘾挣扎的女子育有两个儿子，导致他们的孩子被交由马修的继母抚养。尽管他没有暴力犯罪史，但在1995年至2002年期间，他曾三次出庭，在三次出庭中被判犯有130多项罪行，其中大部分与欺诈指控有关。2002年，他因逃避保释、入室盗窃、盗窃、窝藏赃物、持有海洛因和持有管制武器而被判入狱14个月。2003年出狱后，马修从住房部获得了海洋街公寓大楼的住所。尽管他在随后的13年里没有惹上法律麻烦，但他继续吸食非法毒品。马修的朋友、31岁的康斯坦蒂诺斯·贝利亚里斯是三个儿子之一。他的父母在他很小的时候就离婚了，他由父亲抚养长大，与父亲的关系很紧张，这导致了康斯坦蒂诺斯的愤怒问题。在16岁生日时，由于父亲威胁要将他赶出去，康斯坦蒂诺斯自愿离家出走，在11年级时从高中辍学，开始了一份他从未完成的水管工学徒工作。
Throughout his adult life, he was employed on and off, mainly finding work as a concreter. He battled with anger, drug, and alcohol problems, having started using cannabis as a young teenager. Konstantinos had been a regular user of methamphetamine since he was 17 years old, and to dealt drugs to support his habit. By his mid-20s, he was admitted into psychiatric care twice. During a nine-year on and off de facto relationship, Konstantinos fathered two children. The relationship was marred by violence and domestic incidents, one of which led to Konstantinos being convicted for hindering police using threatening words in a public place and behaving in an offensive manner. He was placed on a bond and required to attend anger management counseling. In June 2013, police were called to the couple's residence after another incident in which Konstantinos had smashed a barrier's household items, including the fridge and a microwave.
在他的成年生活中，他断断续续地工作，主要从事混凝土工的工作。他与愤怒、毒品和酒精问题作斗争，在很小的时候就开始吸食大麻。康斯坦蒂诺斯从17岁起就是甲基苯丙胺的常客，并以贩毒来维持自己的习惯。到20多岁时，他曾两次被送入精神病护理机构。在一段为期九年的断断续续的同居关系中，康斯坦蒂诺斯育有两名儿童。这段关系被暴力和家庭事件所破坏，其中一起事件导致康斯坦蒂诺斯因在公共场所用威胁性言辞妨碍警察并表现出攻击性行为而被定罪。他被勒令遵守保释规定并参加愤怒管理咨询。2013年6月，在另一起康斯坦蒂诺斯砸毁巴里家庭用品（包括冰箱和微波炉）的事件发生后，警方被召集到这对夫妇的住所。
His partner attempted to escape with the children, but Konstantinos smashed her car windows with a stick, fleeing the scene as the police arrived. He returned once the police had left and assaulted his partner again. He returned to the house two months later, smashing more property and was subsequently sentenced to three months in prison and 12 months of community service, which he breached and was later re-arrested for. In December 2014, Konstantinos started dating a single mother named Janet, not her real name, and the pair lived together in the Oceanicy Street apartment complex. By 2015, whilst on bail for two counts of recklessly causing injury, committing an indictable offence whilst on bail and breaking his community corrections order, Konstantinos was in trouble with the law again. High on crystal meth, he broke into the home of a man who owed him a meager amount of money as part of a drug debt, brutally attacking him before stealing his mother's car. Konstantinos was charged with trespass, robbery, and intentionally causing injury. Just weeks before police arrived to make inquiries in relation to Brendon Bernard's murder, Konstantinos had invited his ex-partner to his apartment and upon her arrival, proceeded to push her down a flight of stairs.
他的伴侣试图带着孩子逃跑，但康斯坦蒂诺斯用一根棍子砸碎了她汽车的车窗，并在警察到达时逃离了现场。警察离开后，他又回来了，并再次殴打他的伴侣。两个月后，他回到房子里，砸毁了更多的财产，随后被判处三个月监禁和12个月的社区服务，但他违反了社区服务并不久后再次被捕。2014年12月，康斯坦蒂诺斯开始与一位名叫珍妮（化名）的单身母亲约会，两人同住在海洋街公寓大楼里。到2015年，由于两项鲁莽造成伤害、在保释期间犯下可公诉罪行以及违反社区矫正令的保释期间，康斯坦蒂诺斯再次陷入法律麻烦。在冰毒的驱使下，他闯入了一个欠他少量毒品债务的男子的家中，对其进行了残酷的袭击，然后偷走了他母亲的汽车。康斯坦蒂诺斯被指控犯有非法侵入、抢劫和故意造成伤害罪。就在警方赶来就布伦登·伯纳德谋杀案进行调查的前几周，康斯坦蒂诺斯曾邀请他的前任伴侣到他的公寓，并在她到达后，将她推下一段楼梯。
The third man in the group last sighted with Brendon Bernard was 46-year-old Edward Hill, known by his nickname Nippy. The eldest of several children to his long-time divorced parents, Edward suffered from Perthes disease, a childhood hip disorder that prevented bone growth, causing lifelong deformities and osteoarthritis. He also suffered a mild intellectual disability, which made him the target of schoolyard bullies, causing him to skip school before leaving altogether in year 10. When Edward was 15 years old, he left home, working as a gardener and butcher before dropping out of the workforce entirely at age 18, receiving income from a disability support pension and the Salvation Army. A heavy drinker from an early age, Edward was known to consume liters of poor today and was also a regular user of cannabis, heroin, morphine, and methamphetamine. He had a long criminal history, amassing over 80 convictions from 29 court appearances between 1985 and 2010, mostly for dishonesty, driving, and to drunken disorderly offenses, but also for more violent crimes. In November 2005, he served an eight-month prison sentence for assault-related charges, damaging property, and aggravated burglary. Over the years, he fathered six children, all of whom resided with their respective mothers interstate.
最后一位与布伦登·伯纳德一起被目击到的男子是46岁的爱德华·希尔，绰号“尼皮”。作为长期离婚的父母的几个孩子中的老大，爱德华患有佩尔特斯病，这是一种儿童时期导致骨骼生长的髋关节疾病，会导致终身畸形和骨关节炎。他还患有轻度智力残疾，这使他成为校园霸凌的目标，导致他逃学，最终在10年级时完全退学。爱德华15岁时离家出走，曾做过园丁和屠夫，18岁时完全退出劳动力市场，靠残疾支助抚恤金和救世军的收入生活。爱德华从小就酗酒，众所周知他会喝掉几升劣质酒，并且还是大麻、海洛因、吗啡和甲基苯丙胺的常客。他有着漫长的犯罪记录，在1985年至2010年的29次出庭中积累了80多项定罪，主要因诈骗、驾车和醉酒滋事罪，但也因更暴力的犯罪。2005年11月，他因袭击相关罪行、破坏财产和严重入室盗窃服刑八个月。多年来，他育有六个孩子，他们都与各自的母亲住在外州。
By 2015, Edward had been living in the Oceanicy Street Commission complex for 10 years. It was clear that all three men were of dubious character, but they assured police that Brendan had left Matthew Brennan's apartment weeks earlier to escape the ramifications of a botched drug deal. Unable to find proof of any such situation having occurred, police were convinced the men were lying. Then, one of Edward Hill's neighbors came forward. Eric, not his real name, provided a statement to police in which he claimed, Nippy told me it was him who killed Brendan Bernard. He said Brendan had been given $300 to score drugs, but he returned empty-handed with only $40 left. This prompted Edward to, quote, crack the shits. According to Eric, Edward bragged about killing Brendan, saying, It was easy. I hit him four times, and he just dropped.
到2015年，爱德华已经在海洋街公房大楼住了10年。很明显，这三个男人品行可疑，但他们向警方保证，布伦登几周前就离开了马修·布伦南的公寓，以逃避一次搞砸的毒品交易所带来的后果。在找不到任何此类情况发生的证据后，警方确信这些人在撒谎。然后，爱德华·希尔的一位邻居挺身而出。埃里克（化名）向警方提供了一份声明，他声称：“尼皮告诉我，是杀死布伦登·伯纳德的人。他说布伦登拿到了300澳元去买毒品，但他两手空空地回来了，只剩下40澳元。”这促使爱德华“发飙”。据埃里克说，爱德华吹嘘自己杀死了布伦登，并说：“这很简单。我打了四下，他就倒下了。”
He said Brendan's body had been left in the bathtub for a week before being dismembered by Matthew Brennan and Konstantinos Balearis. Eric's statement was equal parts damning and chilling. However, police were aware that Edward Hill's claims were unreliable due to his intellectual disability, illicit drug use, and excessive alcohol consumption. Nevertheless, Eric stood by his statement, not only willing to testify in court, but also agreeing to serve as a police informant by wearing a concealed wire during further conversations with his neighbor. During these recorded conversations, Edward rambled on about Brendan Bernard, accusing him of trying to sell crushed glass disguised as crystal methamphetamine. Investigators were unable to prove whether these accusations were true, and Edward's unfounded stories only served to raise doubts as to the authenticity of his character, and thus, the validity of his claims that he was responsible for Brendan's death. Police were certain the truth of what happened to Brendan Bernard remained with those who were in Matthew Brennan's apartment on the afternoon of January 27. They brought Matthew, Konstantinos Balearis, and Edward Hill in for questioning, but all three men remained tight lipped regarding what exactly had happened.
他说布伦登的尸体在浴缸里放了一个星期，然后被马修·布伦南和康斯坦蒂诺斯·贝利亚里斯肢解。埃里克的声明既令人震惊又让人不寒而栗。然而，警方意识到爱德华·希尔的说法不可靠，因为他有智力残疾、吸毒和过度饮酒的问题。尽管如此，埃里克坚持他的陈述，不仅愿意在法庭上作证，还同意在与邻居的进一步对话中佩戴隐藏的窃听器担任警察线人。在这些录音对话中，爱德华喋喋不休地谈论着布伦登·伯纳德，指责他试图出售伪装成冰毒的碎玻璃。调查人员无法证明这些指控是否属实，爱德华毫无根据的故事只会引起人们对他品格真实性的怀疑，从而也怀疑他声称自己对布伦登之死负责的言论的有效性。警方确信，关于布伦登·伯纳德遭遇的真相仍然掌握在1月27日下午在马修·布伦南公寓里的那些人手中。他们把马修、康斯坦蒂诺斯·贝利亚里斯和爱德华·希尔带去讯问，但这三名男子对具体发生了什么事都守口如瓶。
They then questioned the final person who was witnessed at the apartment that day, Konstantinos' girlfriend, Janet. To their surprise, Janet expressed a willingness to reveal the truth, in exchange for a plea deal. On Monday, January 26, 2015, Janet and Konstantinos visited Edward Hill's apartment, having befriended him during a drug deal the previous month. When they arrived, Matthew Brennan and Brendan Bernard were already there. Edward introduced Brendan to the couple, and the group settled in, spending the day together drinking alcohol and taking drugs. Janet sold Brendan five morphine tablets for $100 on tick, meaning he agreed to pay her back later, and the pair exchanged phone numbers to facilitate the future transaction. That afternoon, a neighbour complained about the noise the group was making, so they each splintered off and returned to their own apartments. The next day of Tuesday, January 27, Janet phoned Brendan several times, seeking payment for the morphine tablets.
然后，他们讯问了那天在公寓目击到的最后一个人——康斯坦蒂诺斯的男友珍妮。令他们惊讶的是，珍妮表示愿意透露真相，以换取辩诉交易。2015年1月26日星期一，珍妮和康斯坦蒂诺斯拜访了爱德华·希尔的公寓，他们是在上个月的一场毒品交易中与他结交的。他们到达时，马修·布伦南和布伦登·伯纳德已经在那里了。爱德华将布伦登介绍给这对夫妇，大家安顿下来，一起度过了一天，喝酒吸毒。珍妮以100澳元的价格赊销给布伦登五片吗啡药丸，这意味着他同意以后还钱，两人交换了电话号码以促进未来的交易。那天下午，一位邻居抱怨这群人制造的噪音，于是他们各自散开，回到了各自的公寓。第二天，即1月27日星期二，珍妮多次打电话给布伦登，索要吗啡药丸的款项。
She handed the phone to her boyfriend, with Brendan telling Konstantinos he would get the money off his stepfather. After some bartering, Konstantinos agreed to lower the debt to $60. Later that day, Janet and Konstantinos visited Edward's apartment, finding Matthew Brennan already inside. The four spent the afternoon drinking and doing drugs, during which the conversation drifted to Brendan Bernard. Matthew complained about Brendan living at his place rent-free and expecting free drugs, despite having previously agreed to let him stay at his apartment for nothing. As they continued to wear their gripes, tempers began to flare in the group, and they decided to go to Matthew's apartment to confront Brendan. He wasn't home at the time, so the group began rummaging through his belongings, hoping to find cash or drugs they could use as repayment for his debts. As they were ransacking through his things, Brendan suddenly appeared, catching the group red-handed.
她把电话递给男友，布伦丹告诉康斯坦蒂诺斯，他会从继父那里拿到钱。经过一番讨价还价，康斯坦蒂诺斯同意将债务减至60美元。那天晚些时候，珍妮特和康斯坦蒂诺斯来到爱德华的公寓，发现马修·布伦南已经在里面了。四人在下午一起喝酒吸毒，期间谈话转到了布伦丹·伯纳德身上。马修抱怨布伦丹白住他的地方还想白嫖毒品，尽管他之前曾同意让他免费住在自己的公寓里。随着他们继续发牢骚，群里的人情绪开始激动起来，他们决定去马修的公寓找布伦丹对质。他当时不在家，于是这伙人开始翻找他的随身物品，希望能找到现金或毒品来抵债。正当他们搜寻他的东西时，布伦丹突然出现，当场被他们抓了个正着。
They immediately began screaming at him, demanding money. It was chaotic. Brendan was obviously flustered and confused. Konstantinos flew into his trademark rage, punching Brendan repeatedly before Matthew and Edward joined in on the attack. Underweight and weak from years of drug use, Brendan was unable to fight off his three attackers. Instead, he covered his head with his arms in an attempt to protect himself as they continued to beat him whilst repeatedly yelling, You were warned. Konstantinos then placed Brendan in a sleeper-hold until he lost consciousness, dropping his limp body on the lounge-room floor. Janet was ordered to watch over Brendan as the three men entered a bedroom to discuss their next move, closing the door behind them.
他们立刻冲他大喊大叫，索要钱财。现场一片混乱。布伦丹显然慌乱而又困惑。康斯坦蒂诺斯勃然大怒，使出他标志性的暴脾气，对着布伦丹连连出拳，随后马修和爱德华也加入了群殴。由于长期吸毒而骨瘦如柴、身体虚弱，布伦丹根本无法招架这三个袭击者。相反，他用双臂护住头部试图保护自己，而他们则继续殴打他，并不停地大喊：“早就警告过你了。”随后，康斯坦蒂诺斯对布伦丹使出了裸绞，直到他失去知觉，然后将他瘫软的身体扔在了客厅地板上。珍妮特被命令看守布伦丹，而三名男子则走进一间卧室商量下一步行动，并在身后关上了门。
After a few minutes, Brendan regained consciousness and scrambled to his feet. Realizing his attackers were still in the apartment, he made an attempt to flee, but Janet shut and blocked the front door, fearing he would go to the police. She yelled to the others, alerting them that Brendan was trying to escape. Konstantinos, Matthew and Edward rushed out of the bedroom and resumed punching Brendan, wrestling him to the floor. They pushed a pillow over his face to stifle his screams as he continued to yell, I just want to go. I just want to go. The others ordered him to shut up before hauling Brendan into the kitchen where Konstantinos pulled out a black cutthroat razor and slashed him across the face. Janet desperately told her boyfriend, no weapon, but he ignored her.
几分钟后，布伦丹恢复了意识，挣扎着站起身来。意识到袭击者还在公寓里，他试图逃跑，但珍妮特关上并挡住了前门，担心他会去报警。她大声提醒其他人布伦丹正试图逃跑。康斯坦蒂诺斯、马修和爱德华冲出卧室，再次对布伦丹拳打脚踢，将他摔倒在地。他们把枕头死死按在他脸上以压制他的尖叫声，而他则不断大喊：“我只想走。我只想走。”其他人命令他闭嘴，随后把布伦丹拖进厨房，在那里康斯坦蒂诺斯掏出一把黑色剃刀，划破了他的脸。珍妮特绝望地对男友说“不要武器”，但他却置之不理。
The men dragged Brendan kicking and screaming into the bathroom, instructing Janet to close the door behind them. She remained in the kitchen, drinking alcohol to calm her nerves whilst listening to the muffled mix of yelling, screaming and banging coming from the next room. Around 45 minutes later, the chaos finally stopped and everything went quiet. Janet shouted, is everything okay? Is he breathing? To which the men replied, come and have a look. She opened the bathroom door, finding Brendan lying motionless in the bathtub, covered in blood. Konstantinos was holding the ends of a rope pulled tight around Brendan's neck. He held it out to Janet saying, here, have a pull of the dog. When she refused, he gave the rope a forceful tug, causing Brendan's head to hit the side of the tub. As he showed no reaction, Janet asked whether Brendan was still breathing, but the three men didn't answer.
这群人拖着又踢又叫的布伦丹进了浴室，并指示珍妮特在身后关上门。她留在厨房里，喝酒来平复情绪，耳边听着隔壁房间传来的压抑的叫喊声、尖叫声和撞击声的混合杂音。大约45分钟后，混乱终于停止，一切归于寂静。珍妮特大喊：“一切都好吗？他在呼吸吗？”对此，几名男子回答：“进来看看吧。”她打开浴室门，发现布伦丹一动不动地躺在浴缸里，浑身是血。康斯坦蒂诺斯手里拿着一根勒紧在布伦丹脖子上的绳子的两端。他把绳子递给珍妮特说：“来，拉一下这条狗。”当她拒绝时，他用力猛拉绳子，导致布伦丹的头部撞到了浴缸边缘。由于没有任何反应，珍妮特询问布伦丹是否还在呼吸，但这三个男人没有回答。
She put her fingers to his neck but was unable to find a pulse. The group reconvened in the kitchen where Matthew ordered that no one was allowed to leave. Konstantinos appeared unfazed by the situation, at one point asking Matthew if he would mind if he and Janet had sex. Janet remained elusive to police as to whether she engaged in sexual activity with her boyfriend, cutting to another conversation between the group where they discussed the possibility that Brendan had drugs hidden on him. Edward volunteered to search Brendan's body, entering the bathroom alone. He reemerged a short time later, claiming he hadn't found anything. The group were then faced with what to do next.
她把手指放在他的脖子上，却找不到脉搏。这群人在厨房重新聚首，马修下令任何人不准离开。康斯坦蒂诺斯对目前的状况显得无动于衷，甚至一度问马修，他和珍妮特发生性关系是否介意。珍妮特在警方询问她是否与男友发生性行为时闪烁其词，随后话题转到了他们讨论布伦丹身上可能藏有毒品的可能性上。爱德华自告奋勇搜查布伦丹的尸体，独自进入浴室。不久后他重新出现，声称什么也没找到。随后，这群人面临着接下来该怎么做的抉择。
They were unable to move Brendan's body from the apartment as they would no doubt be spotted by their many neighbours. In the days following the murder, his body remained in the bathtub as the group debated what to do. Konstantinos took to wearing Brendan's footwear, expressing his amusement that he was walking around in a dead man's shoes. It was the middle of the sweltering Australian summer, during which temperatures regularly exceeded 35 degrees Celsius. The hot weather caused Brendan's body to decompose at a rapid rate. When a neighbour complained of the awful smell emanating from Matthew's apartment, the group started washing the body to combat the odor. After a week had passed, Konstantinos and Matthew agreed that the ideal way to dispose of Brendan's body without detection was to dismember him. On Tuesday, February 3, seven days after the murder, the three men convened at Matthew's apartment to begin the process of dismembering Brendan's body.
他们无法将布伦丹的尸体从公寓里移走，因为毫无疑问会被他们众多的邻居发现。谋杀案发生后的几天里，他的尸体一直留在浴缸里，而这群人则在争论该怎么处理。康斯坦蒂诺斯开始穿布伦丹的鞋子，并对自已穿着死人鞋子到处走感到好笑。当时正值酷热的澳大利亚夏天，气温经常超过35摄氏度。炎热的天气导致布伦丹的尸体迅速腐烂。当一位邻居抱怨马修公寓里散发出的恶臭时，这群人开始清洗尸体以消除异味。一周过去后，康斯坦蒂诺斯和马修一致认为，在不被发现的情况下处理掉布伦丹尸体的理想方法是将他分尸。2月3日星期二，即谋杀发生七天后，这三名男子在马修的公寓聚首，开始对布伦丹的尸体进行分尸。
Upon completion, the men sealed Brendan's body parts in plastic bags. A while later, Konstantinos retrieved Janet from their shared apartment and she was immediately repulsed by the smell of death that lingered on him. He told her what they had done, boasting that the cut-up flesh looked, quote, good enough to eat. He made specific reference to one of Brendan's legs, stating it looked good enough to roast and that he would have considered eating it if it hadn't been sitting there for so long. He also bragged that it only took them one hour and twenty minutes to complete the task, calling it a record. With Janet in tow, the group of four carried the bags from Matthew's apartment downstairs and out to a car they had stolen. Matthew sat in the back seat as they drove west, spraying a can of Link's deodorant to mask the smell of the remains. They stopped at six different locations along the course of the Maribanong River, throwing the bags into the water at each stop.
完成后，男人们将布伦丹的尸体部位密封在塑料袋里。过了一会儿，康斯坦蒂诺斯把珍妮特从他们合租的公寓里接了过来，她立刻被他身上挥之不去的死亡气味熏得作呕。他把他们做过的事告诉了她，吹嘘那些切碎的肉“看起来好吃得让人想吃”。他特别提到布伦丹的一条腿，声称它看起来烤起来很好吃，如果不是放在那里太久了，他甚至会考虑吃掉它。他还吹嘘他们只用了一个小时二十分钟就完成了任务，称之为一个纪录。在珍妮特的随同下，这四人把袋子从马修的公寓搬到楼下，带到一辆他们偷来的汽车上。当他们向西开车时，马修坐在后座上，喷洒了一罐林克斯除臭剂来掩盖尸臭。他们在马里巴农河沿岸的六个不同地点停了下来，在每一站都把袋子扔进水里。
To hinder efforts to identify their victim once his remains were inevitably discovered, they discarded the bags containing Brendan's head, hands and feet into a council dumpster near a public playground. Following Janet's confession, police arrived to the dumpster where Brendan's head, hands and feet were discarded, but the rubbish had since been collected by a garbage truck and its contents taken to a dump. Janet led police to the six locations along the Maribanong River where the group had discarded the rest of Brendan's remains, with a search of the river recommencing on Friday, February 27. Police released a statement to the media that read, Investigators would like to reassure local residents that the police activity today is an extension of the previous search activity as all the remains have not been found, not as the result of the discovery of additional body parts. Investigators obtained a search warrant for Matthew Brennan's apartment where they found traces of Brendan's blood in the lounge room. They were also able to recover a vacuum cleaner Matthew had since sold to the pawnshop cash converters, which underwent forensic examination and was found to contain traces of Brendan's blood. In subsequent police interviews, Matthew Brennan, Konstantinos Spaliaris and Edward Hill all confessed to killing and dismembering Brendan Bernard before disposing of his body.
为了阻挠一旦尸体不可避免地被发现后对其受害者的辨认工作，他们把装有布伦丹头部、双手和双脚的袋子扔进了公共游乐场附近的市政垃圾箱里。在珍妮特供认后，警察来到了丢弃布伦丹头部、双手和双脚的垃圾箱，但垃圾此时已被垃圾车收走，里面的东西也被运到了垃圾填埋场。珍妮特带领警方来到了马里巴农河沿岸的六个地点，这群人曾将布伦丹剩余的遗体丢弃在那里，对该河的搜寻工作于2月7日星期五重新开始。警方发表了一份媒体声明称：“调查人员希望向当地居民保证，今天展开的警方行动是先前搜寻行动的延续，因为并非所有遗体都已被找到，而不是发现了额外的身体部位。”调查人员获得了对马修·布伦南公寓的搜查令，在那里他们在客厅里发现了布伦丹的血迹。他们还找回了马修随后卖给当铺“现金转换器”的吸尘器，经过法医检查，发现其中含有布伦丹的血迹。在随后的警方讯问中，马修·布伦南、康斯坦蒂诺斯·斯帕利亚里斯和爱德华·希尔都承认杀害并分尸了布伦丹·伯纳德，随后处理掉了他的尸体。
They admitted that Konstantinos and Matthew had used a knife and a hacksaw to cut up Brendan's body while Edward looked on. All three men were charged with murder, to which they pleaded not guilty, claiming their motive was never to kill Brendan, only to hurt him as punishment for owing them money. The trio were denied bail and the trial was ordered to begin the following year, as the complex forensic nature of the case meant police needed extra time to prepare their brief of evidence. They also needed more time to search for Brendan's missing remains. Almost a month later, on Sunday, March 22, a member of the public was walking near the Boathouse Restaurant where Brendan's severed forearm was found 45 days earlier when they spotted some bones. The discovery drew intense media attention, with several reports boldly insinuating that the bones belonged to the murdered 32-year-old. However, forensic testing later confirmed the bones were not human. Despite the extensive efforts by police, no further remains belonging to Brendan Bernard were located.
他们承认，康斯坦蒂诺斯和马修曾用一把刀和一把钢锯切碎了布伦丹的尸体，而爱德华则在一旁观看。这三名男子均被控谋杀，但他们拒不认罪，声称他们的动机从来不是杀死布伦丹，而只是为了惩罚他欠钱而伤害他。这三人被拒绝保释，审判被下令于次年开始，因为该案复杂的法医性质意味着警方需要额外时间来准备证据摘要。他们也需要更多时间来搜寻布伦丹失踪的遗体。将近一个月后的3月22日星期日，一名公众在船屋餐厅附近散步时，发现了45天前找到布伦丹被切断的前臂的地方的一些骨头。这一发现引起了媒体的极大关注，几篇报道大胆暗示这些骨头属于被谋杀的32岁男子。然而，法医检测后来证实这些骨头不是人类的。尽管警方作出了巨大努力，但仍未找到属于布伦丹·伯纳德的更多遗体。
On July 21, a committal hearing determined there was sufficient evidence for the case to go to trial at the Supreme Court. Whilst awaiting trial for murder, Konstantinos Balearis faced court for his early appending charges, which included assault, recklessly causing injury, committing an indictable offence whilst on bail, and breaking his community corrections order. He was convicted on all counts and sentenced to nine months in prison. Brendan Bernard's murder trial began the following year on Monday, May 23, 2016, overseen by presiding judge Justice John Beale. In his opening address, Chief Crown Prosecutor Gavin Silbert told the court, You are about to embark on another one of the increasing number of murder cases arising from the world of drugs, and in particular, the drug ICE. Following the prosecution's opening, the defense counsel immediately put in an application to discharge the jury, reasoning Silbert's comments were, quote, irrelevant, factually incorrect, and highly prejudicial to the accused.
7月21日，一场预审听证会确定有足够证据将该案提交至最高法院审判。在等待谋杀案审判期间，康斯坦蒂诺斯·巴勒里is因其早期的未决指控出庭，这些指控包括袭击、鲁莽致伤、在保释期间犯下可公诉罪行以及违反社区矫正令。他在所有指控上都被判有罪，并被判处九个月监禁。布伦丹·伯纳德的谋杀案审判于次年（2016年5月23日星期日）开始，由主审法官约翰·比尔主持。在开庭陈述中，首席皇家检察官加文·西尔伯特对法庭表示：“你们即将开始审判又一起越来越多的源自毒品世界的谋杀案，特别是冰毒案件。”在检察官发表开庭陈述后，辩护律师立即提出申请解散陪审团，理由是西尔伯特的言论“无关紧要、事实错误，且对被告具有高度偏见”。
The prevalence of ICE, also known as crystal methamphetamine, had risen dramatically amongst drug users in Victoria over the previous years, causing a sharp increase in violent crimes, including homicides. The defense argued the prosecution's comments skewed the trial to represent the wider societal problems arising from the ICE epidemic, and that it, quote, invites the jury to associate this offense with the topical social evil in an inappropriate way. Justice Beale permitted the trial to continue, but reminded the jury to focus on Brendan's murder and not the associated drug use or its wider social impacts. The defense of all three of the accused invited the jury to convict their clients on the lesser charge of manslaughter, explaining their motive was to cause serious injury, not death. Konstantinos' attorney argued that his client's intent was to, quote, merely give the man a flogging, although conceding that he hadn't been disappointed by the result. The defense also insisted that their clients having accepted responsibility for Brendan's death was evident of their remorse for their actions. The prosecution's assertions that the dismemberment was an aggravating factor of the murder was disputed by the defense.
冰毒（又称结晶甲基苯丙胺）在维多利亚州的吸毒者中盛行，在过去几年里急剧上升，导致暴力犯罪（包括凶杀案）急剧增加。辩护方辩称，检察官的言论扭曲了审判，使其代表了由冰毒泛滥引起的更广泛的社会问题，并且“邀请陪审团以不恰当的方式将这起犯罪与这个热门的社会恶习联系起来”。比尔法官允许审判继续进行，但提醒陪审团重点关注布伦丹的谋杀案，而不是相关的吸毒或其更广泛的社会影响。三名被告的辩护律师均请求陪审团以较轻的过失杀人罪对他们的当事人定罪，解释说他们的动机是造成严重伤害，而不是死亡。康斯坦蒂诺斯的律师辩称，其当事人的意图是“仅仅给这个人一顿狠狠的毒打”，尽管他承认他对结果并不感到失望。辩护方还坚称，他们的当事人承认对布伦丹的死负责，这证明了他们对其行为的悔意。辩护方对检察官关于分尸是谋杀加重情节的主张提出了异议。
They referenced other murder cases where the victim's body was mutilated immediately following the killing, unlike Brendan's dismemberment, which occurred a week after he had died. They maintained that the desecration of Brendan's body was the result of a drug-induced panic, not aimed to further humiliate him or seek vengeance. Judge Beale wasn't convinced, stating his opinion that the defendant's motivation behind dismembering Brendan's body was a calculated decision to evade punishment. The prosecution's case relied heavily on the witness testimony provided by Konstantinos' former girlfriend, Janet. The couple had since separated, with Konstantinos resuming his relationship with the mother of his children, whom he had abused on multiple occasions. The defense worked to discredit Janet by drawing attention to her history of drug and alcohol abuse, as well as to the lack of confidence she had in her own testimony. As she had admitted to consuming alcohol and using ICE immediately prior to and during Brendan's attack, Janet was made out to be an unreliable witness. Matthew Brennan's attorney told the jury,
他们参考了其他谋杀案，在这些案件中，受害者的身体在被杀后立即遭到肢解，这与布伦丹在死后一周才被分尸不同。他们坚称，对布伦丹尸体的亵渎是吸毒引起的恐慌的结果，并非旨在进一步羞辱他或寻求复仇。比尔法官对此并不买账，他表示，被告分尸布伦丹的动机是为了逃避惩罚而做出的有计划的决定。检察官的案件严重依赖康斯坦蒂诺斯的前女友珍妮特提供的证人证言。这对情侣后来分居了，康斯坦蒂诺斯恢复了与他曾多次虐待的孩子母亲的关系。辩护方通过提请人们注意她有吸毒和酗酒的历史，以及她对自己的证词缺乏信心，试图抹黑珍妮特。由于珍妮特承认在袭击布伦丹之前和期间曾饮酒并吸食冰毒，她被描绘成一个不可靠的证人。马修·布伦南的律师对陪审团说：
She is the only witness to what happened in that living room. You appreciate by now this is a different world you're going into. Everyone in that room was drug-affected or drunk. Janet said she couldn't go out in public unless she'd had something to drink. You'll be focusing very carefully on her evidence. How reliable is it? However, upon cross-examination, Janet's version of events were exactly as she had described during her initial confession to police. She admitted to using drugs that day, saying,
她是那间客厅里发生的事情的唯一见证人。大家现在应该意识到，你将要进入的是一个不同的世界。那个房间里的每个人都受到了毒品影响或者喝醉了。珍妮特说，除非喝了点酒，否则她不敢去公众场合。你们将非常仔细地关注她的证据。它有多可靠？然而，在盘问时，珍妮特对事件的描述与她最初向警方供认时完全一致。她承认那天吸了毒，并说：
We all had our poison, but her story remained the same. When reliving the first punch that initiated the ferocious attack on Brendan, she explained, It was like a big ball of arms and the legs. It was a pretty big mess. There were three people that was yelling. The dog was barking and biting. I was saying stop. Janet broke down in tears as she told the jury how Brendan had cried throughout his ordeal, begging his attackers to stop. When the accused realized Brendan had died, Janet explained, It's like they weren't having fun anymore, because he wasn't alive anymore.
我们都有各自的毒药，但她的故事依然没有变。当重温引发对布伦丹凶猛袭击的第一记重拳时，她解释说：“就像一大团胳膊和腿。那是一团相当大的乱麻。有三个人在叫喊。狗在叫咬。我说过停下来。”珍妮特泪流满面地向陪审团讲述了布伦丹在整个折磨过程中是如何哭泣的，乞求袭击者住手。当被告意识到布伦丹已经死亡时，珍妮特解释说：“就好像他们不再觉得好玩了，因为他已经不在了。”
She admitted to closing the front door of the apartment on Brendan when he made an effort to escape, as she didn't want him to alert police and to risk Konstantinos going back to jail. A large amount of Janet's credibility centered around the duration of the fight that led to Brendan's death. She was certain the assault lasted for a couple of hours, beginning with a 15 minute verbal argument, followed by a 15 minute physical fight in the lounge room, which then rendered Brendan unconscious for another 15 minutes. When Brendan came to and tried to escape, another 10 minute fight ensued, and his final ordeal in the bathroom lasted up to 45 minutes. However, this conflicted with the testimony provided by the neighbor who lived in the apartment above Matthew Brennan, who told the court that the fight he overheard only lasted 10 to 20 minutes.
她承认，当布伦丹试图逃跑时，她把公寓的前门关上了，因为她不想让他报警，从而冒着康斯坦蒂诺斯重返监狱的风险。珍妮特的可信度很大程度上取决于导致布伦丹死亡的打斗持续时间。她确信袭击持续了几个小时，开始是15分钟的口角，接着是客厅里的15分钟肢体冲突，随后布伦丹失去知觉另外15分钟。当布伦丹醒来并试图逃跑时，又发生了10分钟的打斗，他在浴室里的最后折磨长达45分钟。然而，这与住在马修·布伦南楼上的邻居提供的证词相矛盾，后者告诉法庭，他无意中听到的打斗只持续了10到20分钟。
The defense argued that Janet's incorrect timings were evidence of her inability to factually recall key details of the event, but Janet stood by her testimony, stating, Everything was a blur around that time in my life. I remember clearly everything that happened, but the time frames are a bit fuzzy. As Janet hadn't witnessed the events that unfolded in the bathroom, it was unclear exactly what had occurred within. Konstantinos Spaliaris was accused of being solely responsible for this most savage portion of the attack. He admitted the events that transpired were beyond the scope of what he and his co-accused had agreed to, and that when he had choked Brendan with the robe, he had done so without Matthew Brennan or Edward Hill's explicit approval.
辩护方辩称，珍妮特错误的时间记录证明了她无法事实性地回忆起事件的关键细节，但珍妮特坚持自己的证词，称：“我生命中的那个时期一切都是模糊的。我清楚地记得发生的一切，但时间框架有点模糊。”由于珍妮特没有目睹浴室里发生的事情，目前尚不清楚里面到底发生了什么。康斯坦蒂诺斯·斯帕利亚里斯被指控对这起袭击中最野蛮的部分负有全部责任。他承认发生的事情超出了他和同案被告商定的范围，而且当他用袍子勒住布伦丹时，他是在没有得到马修·布伦南或爱德华·希尔明确批准的情况下这样做的。
Furthermore, Matthew's legal counsel extensively highlighted the fact that despite the bathroom belonging to their client, there was no forensic evidence to place him at the scene of the murder. There was also no evidence to indicate who was present during each portion of the attack, or who administered the fatal injury that ended Brendan's life. The extensive damage caused to Brendan's recovered remains failed to provide an answer, with the exact cause of his death remaining a mystery. In an effort to explain the presence of Brendan's blood in Matthew's apartment and vacuum cleaner, the defense counsel claimed Brendan had gotten into a number of fights leading up to his death,
此外，马修的法律顾问广泛强调了一个事实，即尽管浴室属于他们的客户，但没有法医证据将他置于谋杀现场。也没有证据表明在袭击的每个部分期间谁在场，或者是谁实施了结束布伦丹生命的致命伤。布伦丹找回的遗体所受到的广泛破坏未能提供答案，他的具体死因仍然是个谜。为了解释马修公寓和吸尘器中存在布伦丹血迹的原因，辩护律师声称布伦丹在死前卷入了多起打斗，
and the spatter had likely resulted from one of these incidents. After an 18-day trial followed by seven days of deliberations, the jury reached its final verdict on Friday, June 10, 2016. For the murder of Brendan Bernard, Konstantinos Balearis, Matthew Brennan, and Edward Hill were unanimously found guilty. When the verdict was announced, Brendan's family led out cries of relief and embraced one another in tears. As the jury left the court, Konstantinos and Matthew were seen smiling and joking with one another. During the subsequent sentencing hearing, victim impact statements were read out to the court. An emotional reading from Brendan's father, Ronald Whitmore, expressed how disgusted and enraged he felt over his son's murder,
血迹很可能是这些事件之一造成的。经过18天的审判和7天的审议，陪审团于2016年6月10日星期五做出了最终裁决。对于谋杀布伦丹·伯纳德，康斯坦蒂诺斯·巴勒里is、马修·布伦南和爱德华·希尔被一致裁定有罪。当宣判结果宣布时，布伦丹的家人发出了如释重负的欢呼声，并含泪拥抱在一起。当陪审团离开法庭时，人们看到康斯坦蒂诺斯和马修互相微笑着开玩笑。在随后的量刑听证会上，法庭宣读了受害者影响陈述。布伦丹的父亲罗纳德·惠特莫尔情绪激动地宣读了一份声明，表达了他对儿子被谋杀感到多么恶心和愤怒，
and the way he was treated after his death. He described the murder as a senseless, small-minded, and cowardly act, adding that the lack of humanity shown by his son's killers would stay with him forever. Despite the best efforts by police, Bernard's head, hands, feet, and a significant portion of his body were never recovered. Ronald demanded his son's killers reveal the whereabouts of his remains. Quote, Ronald described the turmoil he felt having to opt for cremation instead of burial due to how little of Brendan's body was found. Whilst his family had long feared they would one day lose Brendan to a drug overdose,
以及他死后受到的对待。他将这场谋杀描述为一场毫无意义、思想狭隘和懦弱的行为，并补充说，他儿子杀手表现出的缺乏人性将永远伴随着他。尽管警方尽了最大努力，但伯纳德的头部、双手、身体的大部分以及双脚始终没有被找到。罗纳德要求他儿子的杀手透露他遗体的下落。原话是：“罗纳德描述了由于找到的布伦丹尸体太少而不得不选择火化而不是土埋时感到的痛苦。”虽然他的家人长期以来一直担心有一天会因吸毒过量而失去布伦丹，
Ronald remarked that what happened instead was far worse, stating, I would like Brendan to be remembered as the boy he was and not the man he could have been. I loved him, and I always will. Victim impact statements were also read on behalf of Brendan's siblings, giving the otherwise private family the opportunity to publicly express their grief. Brendan's brother described how his world stopped upon identifying Brendan's forearm, as though he was outside his body, watching a play. He also expressed sadness that Brendan's body was disposed of like garbage.
罗纳德评论说，发生的事情反而要糟糕得多，他宣称：“我希望布伦丹被记住的是他曾经的那个男孩，而不是他本来可以成为的那个男人。我爱他，我将永远爱他。”法庭还代表布伦丹的兄弟姐妹宣读了受害者影响陈述，让这个原本低调的家庭有机会公开表达他们的悲痛。布伦丹的哥哥描述了他的世界在认出布伦丹的前臂时是如何停止转动的，就好像他站在自己的身体之外，看着一出戏。他还对布伦丹的尸体像垃圾一样被处理掉表示难过。
Quote, He was my flesh and blood. He was my brother. He died for $60, which I found out was probably actually paid. It was discovered that the $60 debt that led to Brendan's murder had in fact been paid. On January 27, 2015, after visiting his stepfather in the city to borrow the money, Brendan had trusted the $60 payment to his roommate, Matthew Brennan, requesting he pass the cash on to Janet to repay his debt. Instead of giving the money to Janet, Matthew decided to pocket it for himself.
原话是：“他是我的骨肉。他是我的兄弟。他为60美元而死，我发现这笔钱其实可能已经付了。”人们发现，导致布伦丹被谋杀的60美元债务其实已经还清了。2015年1月27日，布伦丹在市区拜访继父借钱后，将这60美元的还款托付给他的室友马修·布伦南，并请求他把现金转交给珍妮特以偿还债务。马修没有把钱给珍妮特，而是决定把钱据为己有。
He kept his theft a secret from the others, even when Brendan's alleged failure to repay the debt sparked the group's confrontation. Brendan was genuinely blindsided by the attack, confused as to why the group were demanding money from him, which he had already paid. At the sentencing hearing, Justice John Beall rejected the defense's argument that the dismemberment of Brendan's body occurred too long after the killing to be treated as a circumstance of aggravation, stating, The three of you disposed of the body parts, and I regard that as a further aggravating circumstance. Justice Beall declared the defense team's effort to persuade the jury to convict the trio of manslaughter as a pragmatic tactical decision to maximize their chances of being found not guilty of murder. He did not believe it flowed from any semblance of remorse from the defendants, and didn't accept any statements relied on by the defense that attempted to indicate otherwise.
他将盗窃行为对其他人保密，甚至当布伦丹被指控未能还清债务引发这群人的对质时也是如此。布伦丹对这次袭击完全蒙在鼓里，对这群人为什么向他索要他已经付清的钱感到困惑。在量刑听证会上，法官约翰·比尔驳回了辩护方的论点，即布伦丹尸体的分尸发生得太久，不应被视为加重情节，并表示：“你们三人处理了尸体部位，我认为这是进一步的加重情节。”比尔法官宣称，辩护团队说服陪审团将三人定为过失杀人罪的努力是一种务实的战术决定，旨在最大化他们被判谋杀罪不成立的机会。他不认为这源于被告的任何一丝悔意，也不接受辩护方试图暗示相反情况的任何声明。
Justice Beall told the convicted men, The impact of your offending on Mr. Bernard's family is profound and enduring. The anguish they feel has impacted on their physical and mental health. What you did to Mr. Bernard before and after his death understandably dominates their thoughts. They continue to be tormented by the fact that parts of Mr. Bernard have not been recovered. He concluded, Given the lack of evidence as to what happened in the bathroom where Mr. Bernard was killed, I cannot be satisfied that there was an agreement to kill. Nonetheless, your moral culpability is still high.
比尔法官对被定罪的男人们说：“你们的犯罪行为对伯纳德先生家庭的影响是深远且持久的。他们感到的痛苦已经影响了他们的身体和精神健康。你们对伯纳德先生生前和死后所做的事情理所当然地主导了他们的思绪。他们继续被伯纳德先生的部分遗体尚未被找回这一事实折磨着。”他总结道：“鉴于缺乏关于伯纳德先生被杀害的浴室里发生了什么的证据，我不能确信存在杀人协议。尽管如此，你们的道德罪责仍然很高。”
This was a protracted, brutal, and cowardly assault by the three of you. The rehabilitation prospects for Konstantinos Valiaris, Matthew Brennan, and Edward Hill were respectively regarded as poor, fair, and uncertain. During the trial, Edward Hill had been assessed by a neuropsychologist who concluded his IQ was a mere 68, placing him in the bottom 2.2% of the population. The impairment was present throughout his brain development and further compromised by substance abuse during his adolescence, impacting his general functioning, behavior, reasoning, and problem-solving skills, as well as his decision-making and judgment. It was determined that people with his mild intellectual disability generally require a supportive environment and significant training to function in their lives effectively. Notably, the neuropsychologists' report concluded that Edward Hill was more likely to be vulnerable to influences within his immediate environment. Based on the findings of this report, Justice Beale agreed to take the accused's intellectual disability into account upon determining his sentence.
这是一场由你们三人发起的旷日持久、残忍且懦弱的袭击。康斯坦蒂诺斯·瓦利亚里斯、马修·布伦南和爱德华·希尔的矫正前景分别被视为较差、一般和不确定。在审判期间，爱德华·希尔接受了一位神经心理学家的评估，该评估得出结论，他的智商仅为68，使其处于人口的底2.2%。这种损伤贯穿了他的大脑发育，并在其青春期由于滥用药物而进一步恶化，影响了他的总体功能、行为、推理和问题解决技能，以及他的决策和判断力。据确定，有轻度智力残疾的人通常需要一个支持性的环境和大量的培训才能在生活中有效地发挥作用。值得注意的是，神经心理学家的报告得出结论，爱德华·希尔更容易受到其直接环境中各种影响的影响。根据这份报告的调查结果，比尔法官同意在确定他的刑期时将被告的智力残疾考虑在内。
On Friday, February 3, 2017, two years to the day after they dumped Brendon Bernard's remains in the Marabinong River, Justice Beale sentenced his three killers to prison. Konstantinos Valiaris was handed a 24-year prison term with a non-parole period of 19 years. Matthew Brennan was given 22 years imprisonment with a non-parole period of 17 years, and Edward Hill 20 years imprisonment with a non-parole period of 15 years. Konstantinos received the harshest punishment due to his history of violent crimes, coupled with the attitude and disrespect he showed Brendon during and after his death. Edward Hill's sentence was the lightest due to his intellectual disability and the fact that he had not participated in the dismemberment of Brendon's body. Given the three men had already been incarcerated for a period of 690 days, this time served was deducted from Matthew Brennan and Edward Hill's sentences. Konstantinos Valiaris's sentence, however, was only reduced by 367 days. All three men appealed their sentences on the grounds there was insufficient evidence to warrant a conviction and that the verdict was unreasonable.
2017年2月3日星期五，即他们在马拉比农河倾倒布伦丹·伯纳德遗体整整两周年之际，比尔法官判处他的三名杀手入狱服刑。康斯坦蒂诺斯·瓦利亚里斯被判处24年监禁，不得假释期为19年。马修·布伦南被判处22年监禁，不得假释期为17年，爱德华·希尔被判处20年监禁，不得假释期为15年。由于康斯坦蒂诺斯有暴力犯罪史，加上他在布伦丹死前和死后表现出的态度和不尊重，他受到了最严厉的惩罚。爱德华·希尔的刑期最短，因为他有智力残疾，且他没有参与分尸布伦丹的尸体。鉴于这三名男子已经被关押了690天，这段服刑时间从马修·布伦南和爱德华·希尔的刑期中扣除。然而，康斯坦蒂诺斯·瓦利亚里斯的刑期仅减去了367天。这三名男子均以证据不足以支撑定罪且裁决不合理为由对他们的刑期提出上诉。
They reiterated their issues with the prosecution's opening address at trial, in which they compared the case to the broader ICE epidemic plaguing society and the judge's decision not to dismiss the jury immediately following the remarks. They maintained they had never intended to kill Brendon Bernard and that money was the motivating factor of the assault. Appeal Judge Christopher Maxwell called the attack a vicious joint assault and before rejecting all three appeals asked the convicted men, if you were concerned about the money, why not let the poor bloke go? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们重申了他们对庭审中检察官开庭陈述的问题，在开庭陈述中，他们将该案与困扰社会的更广泛的冰毒泛滥进行了比较，以及法官在言论发表后决定不立即解散陪审团的决定。他们坚称，他们从未打算杀死布伦丹·伯纳德，金钱是袭击的动机。上诉法官克里斯托弗·麦克斯韦称这次袭击是一场恶毒的联合袭击，在驳回所有三项上诉之前，他质问被定罪的男人们：“如果你对钱有顾虑，为什么不放过那个可怜的家伙？”本集尚无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。